welcome to bananamores i can't even
contain my excitement for this next
comedian
all you people watching at home get
those hands of clapping
banana bars comedy club my favorite
virtual
comedy club in the world that also takes
place
in my living room yeah
i know you guys are excited to hear my
set i'll tell you who's not excited to
hear my set
my neighbor rick that shares a wall with
me and quarantine i've been doing a lot
of zoom comedy shows
and he'll bang on the wall and say give
up
he's just pissed because in quarantine
i've grown a bigger mustache than he has
so
get over it rick my dad has now i do
feel
bad for him though because i do scream a
lot
i have severe adhd okay
and get excited really really fast
like i was the girl on the roller
coaster that used to scream
right before the drop i'd be like
my friends would be like shut up we're
in an uber and i'd be like
i also don't pay attention to anything
because of my adhd
uh so if you were to surgically cut me
open i wonder how many of those stickers
on those apples you will find
cause i just plow through those because
i don't pay attention i get a lot of
words and meanings
wrong i thought the word gyrate my
entire life
meant to change the subject until
last week i was in virtual therapy and
my therapist was like okay
let's dig deep and i was like no no no
you and me let's gyrate
she was like what it's like you and me
we're gonna gyrate and now i don't have
a therapist she was too expensive
anyways i learned what the
word meant and i've been using it a lot
my roommates used to get in
huge arguments and i'd be like everyone
just shut up and gyrate
i'm gonna go to their rooms and that
would be the end of that so
i am in the dating game uh for women
whoa we're shocked now now it's fun i'm
really happy because the last time
that i went on a date with the guy i was
screaming in the uber over to the
restaurant okay my voice was tired so it
was low
and i sat down with him and he was like
hey
you have a garbage disposal voice i was
like you shut the hell up
and then i left but i had to pay for it
because i do have a bigger mustache than
he does as well
uh no it's not great okay let's gyrate
uh i did do some babysitting in l.a for
some really bougie
families um you know and
what's the best part about babysitting
yeah that's right rick
it is the food but in la it's not as fun
because they'll be like help yourself to
anything in the house
and you open the cabinet and it's one
almond that's unsalted
but i found trix cereal at the last
place i babysat for
so i'm thinking yahtzee i grabbed the
weird milk and the weird container from
the fridge
and i make myself a fat bowl and the mom
comes home later
and she goes
i'm so tired but i still have to pump
the milk i used in the fridge was her
breast milk
but the weirdest part was it was the
best
bowl of cereal i have ever had and now i
crave it and when i'm in large groups of
women my stomach starts to rumble
i'm like okay all right
am i gay or am i just hungry all right
banana morris you've been amazing
rick you've been a hell of a time thanks
so much i'm audrey stewart
i can't even get over how much talent
this person has it's downright unfair
they got all the talent and left me with
none